άλλος δεν έρχεται απιλιτικά δεν έρχεται για να επιβάλλει μέτρα αλλά για να μιλήσει μαζί
τους να τους βοηθήσει ομίςω όπως όλα είναι καλύτερα τώρα έχουμε θεσμού θετήσεικάπω εκείνη τη
βραδιά ναι να πηγαίνουν δεν θα καναζι μιές μόνοποις ακριβώς δεν θα καμού ζημιές γιατί
κινδυνέύουν και οιδικαι οι άλλη γύρω τους όσο γίνεται θέλει χρόνον αυτό παίνουμε μαζί τους
μπαίνουν οι διευθυνται στο σχολείον για κεβάζουν και το πανό του στο οποίον ελέγχουμε εμποπριν
να μην έχγί βομολοχίες και λιπα και έτσι έχει λίγο γίνει κουλτούρα πια αυτό οιδικά
στη λευκωσίασύστημα διορισμού στη δημόσια ανεκπέρεύσε δεν κάνω λά θεστόχω επτάπλησιάζει που φέρνει κια την
κατάργηση του καταλόγοο που βρίσκετ αυτονναι είμαστε στη νομική υπηρεσία είναι ένα θέματοποί θέλει νομική
ρηθμηση έχουμε διαφορετικές απόψεις μετάξει των εκπαιδευτικόν οργανώσεο ν άλλοι θέλουν να διατηρηθεί ο κατάλογος
αλλά να βρούμε και άλλους τρόπους εξεβρεσης προσωπικού και κάποιο άλλοι θέλουν να συνεχιστεί ο
κατάλογους και ι άλλα χρόνια εμείς ξεκάθαρα είπαμε ότι είμαστε υπέρτις στήρησης της νομοθεσίας αλλά
σίγουρα με βελτίωση των εξετάσειων γιατί υπάρχει σοβαρό θεμα εκεί και σίγουρα με ξέβρεση νάλλολύσεων
ευτυχώσει οι συνεργάτες μας έχουν ισιγήσεις τις επξεργαζόμαστε πάντα με τη βοήθεια της νομικής υπηρεσίας
δεν προκείνεται να κάνουμε κάτι βεβιασμένα βιαστικά επιδή μας το ζητούν θέλω να εμαστε έτοιμη
και αυτοί διαδικασία που θα περάσουμε να μην βάζει αποβαντο τότι υπήρξεπαραδοχή από την ίδηα
να την υπουργών παιδίασ ότι τα παιδιά μας σήμερα διδάσκονται περιτύησίγουρα μόνο προβληματισμόύ προγάνι μπορούμε
τα επόμενα χρόνια αυτή περιτύλη μια να μην υπάρχει στα βιβλία και τα παιδιά ηδιάδεικα
να μην διαβάζουν τα συγκιακιμένα πράγματα ίδη από ότην πρώτη στιγμή οργανόσαμε νομάδεις εργασίας σε
αυτές τις ομάδες δούλεψαν θαράντατρεις ομάδες πέρσει